the gold medal winner for narrative film
goes to the gold medal for international
narrative goes to my nephew Emmett what
you will say god bless you all thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's austere day I feel like I'm
procrastinating if you like if I stand
up now I have to think of 1,000 things
and I don't want to do this it's still
rainy I guess or isn't I don't know yeah
our powers out in our room I didn't know
if it was Hotel wide cuz I gotten stuck
in the elevator as well so do you think
we should all just take the stairs or
gotta take the stairs you know I don't
know if you remember this but we're in
New York he's and I was going to the 48
hour film project ceremony it was 2012
and I got stuck in the elevator in
attitude it was oh we won but maybe
that's it maybe that is the ritual of us
winning huge drag on the way to the
other place with the rest of the team
you'll be doing hair makeup they're
being nominated for an Oscar is the most
real experience I had in my life so far
we are very thrilled and honored and we
are so happy to be here with the whole
team how are you guys how are you
feeling today this is our managers our
cinematographers producer and nominee to
be us Rosen
[Music]
we're getting ready to go to the Academy
Awards which is it's kind of surreal you
know I'm still in film school so I never
really thought not ever really get to
this point we won a student Academy
Award it was like that was enough for us
we didn't even think we'd get that far
almost everybody who's here worked for
free in this movie my wife and I went
through a lot a lot financially and for
it to end in all this let us know that
the risk that we took was worth it and
you know a crazy story we didn't get to
go to prom to get in high school were
highschool sweethearts and you know
we've always talked about
a time when we would be able to make
that for not going to prom together and
so now I have a tuck she has a gown or
going to the Oscars and this like one of
the best make prom makeups that you
could ask for
everything's great
people are very nervous here but we will
get some champagne now and then leave
for the Oscars I hope an Oscar
nomination is a great draw for all of us
me right now I have amazing meetings
with some production companies and
they're really interested in talking to
me it means as well that your film gets
the appreciation so many people are
proud of this and put their passion and
love into it and now the message of this
film and the film is
spreads around the book we went to the
red carpet which I only saw on
television so far and that was also
crazy and surreal and semi Hayek was
right behind us
which was amazing
[Music]
it was a madhouse man showed up at the
red carpet he's seen on television line
I really don't feel how powerful that
moment is until you're actually there
it's overwhelming for sure from
Hollywood and Highland it's the Oscars
when I first walked into the Dolby
theater I was mesmerized it looks way
bigger in person than it does on
television these are the 90th Academy
Awards this is history happening right
here it's nerve-racking when they got to
about three more before our category
gasps stage manager came out and asked
my wife and I to move down to a seat
closer to the stage that was the moment
who were like oh my goodness here we go
the Oscar goes to a silent child Chris
Overton and Rachael senses even though
we didn't win I enjoyed it a lot I was
surprised how I was not disappointed at
all I really liked that people who won
and I'm very happy for them and I was
very relieved that I didn't have to go
up there and talk to the audience once
they announced a winner and it wasn't my
nephew him it I was totally relieved I
was happy for the silent child you know
I'm sitting here in this like second or
third row at the Oscars and I'm watching
common before no I couldn't ask for
anything more
the whole experience was amazing and it
means a lot to me I think there are a
lot of good projects out there maybe
waiting for me so I'm very hopeful for
my future career well now that I have
children I just want to put out content
that they'll watch and learn from you
know because I'm constantly thinking
about them and what I'll leave for them
in the world one that once I'm dead and
gone
[Music]
you